-Our first guest tonight is
a two-time Emmy Award-winning
actress you know from her work
as Karen Walker
on "Will & Grace."
New episodes air Thursday nights
at 9:30, here on NBC.
Let's take a look.
-♪♪ Good riddance, goodbye ♪♪
♪♪ Every trick of his,
you're onto ♪♪
♪♪ But fools will be fools ♪♪
♪♪ And where's he gone to? ♪♪
-Please welcome back to the show
our friend Megan Mullally,
everyone!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
Welcome back!
-Thank you!
Thanks for having me.
-Delighted to have you.
Do you like when you get to
show off your musical chops
in an episode like that?
-Well, I mean, I know
everybody was probably
expecting jokes,
and then I started singing,
but I think, like, pretty much,
like 10 people know that I sing.
But I kind of started
as a singer,
and I've done Broadway musicals
and stuff like that.
So it was so nice of the writers
to write this episode
where I get to sing.
-That's great!
-It's pretty cool, yeah.
-And you're actually
coming here to New York
to perform with --
you have a partner.
-Yeah.
-A singing duo.
Nancy and Beth.
-Nancy and Beth.
This is Stephanie Hunt.
That's me.
And we have
this really fun band.
We sing in harmony,
and every song is choreographed
by me from top to bottom.
And we wear
little matching outfits.
And we have five pieces
behind us.
it's this really cool band.
It's hard to describe.
It's just very celebratory.
and different.
-That's awesome.
Is it great to return
to those roots and
be onstage, singing like that?
-Oh, yeah.
The band, in many ways,
is kind of my favorite thing,
just because,
with Stephanie and I,
it's like two little girls
playing, you know.
-Yeah.
-It's just pure creativity.
-And you do have
a lot of control
when you're not doing it
as a television show.
When you actually just go out
in front of an audience,
it must just feel so freeing.
-Yeah, it's fun,
because we call it
punk vaudeville sometimes,
because there's no way
to make up our own category.
But we get out there
and the songs --
the songs are really sharp.
And then it all just
falls to pieces in between.
-[ Laughing ] Uh-huh.
-You know?
-We're like,
"Now what do we do?"
We don't have anything planned.
-That's great.
-It's great.
-You just went through
the awards circuit,
you were at the Golden Globes.
Did you have a good time
at the Globes?
-Did you get to bump into people
that you were excited to see?
-I did. I've got the secret.
So, if you're --
If you're ever going to
present the Golden Globes --
and I'm sure most of you will...
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
...go -- just hang out
in the greenroom.
Like, don't go sit there,
just go straight backstage,
through an alley,
sit in the greenroom,
and wait until it's your time,
and then leave,
because, you know, you get to,
like, people-watch.
And I was standing there,
talking to --
This is my favorite thing
that happened.
I was talking to Sam Elliott,
who is really tight
with my husband,
if you can imagine that much --
-Your husband, Nick Offerman,
and Sam Elliott.
-Yeah, Nick Offerman.
-That makes perfect sense.
-That much testosterone.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's like ultra man, you know?
-Did they meet, like,
chopping down trees
in the woods?
-Yes, exactly.
[ Laughter ]
And so I was talking to Sam,
and Harrison Ford wandered up
to say hello to Sam.
I don't know him.
Sam introduced me.
And I said, "Hello."
And I said, "you know what?
You were one of my all-time
favorite guests on 'Letterman.'
You were so funny, because
he would ask you a question,
and you would just go, 'No.'"
[ Laughter ]
Like, he had this weird thing
going with Letterman.
And he goes, "Oh!
How is Dave?"
And I was like, "I don't know."
And he said...
[ Laughter ]
..."I hope he's well."
And he said, "Oh, I thought
you were a writer."
And I said, "No, I'm an actress.
I just presented."
And he goes, "Ohh!"
I said, "I'm
on a television show.
You wouldn't know."
And he goes, "Oh, gosh. Oh!"
And I said, [Baby talk]
"Harrison made a boo-boo."
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ]
And he literally went,
[Baby talk[ "He did."
[ Laughter ]
"He did make a boo-boo."
[ Normal voice ] And I thought,
"I love this guy."
-That's the greatest interaction
you possibly could've had.
-He went full baby talk.
-Wow!
-Yeah.
-What a jackpot!
-I know.
-Also, when you meet somebody
who is a giant icon like that,
it's so great
when they're the one
who makes the mistake.
-Totes.
-Because usually,
the lower-status person
gets nervous and screws up.
-Yeah.
-But he blew it.
And then you got to
reap the reward.
-And, I mean,
it was so delightful.
-Yeah. That's just great.
And then you hosted,
and you were wonderful
at the SAG Awards.
-Oh, that's very nice of you.
I had a lot of fun.
-Did you enjoy that?
-I did.
I had, you know, great --
Everybody was great,
and I had a lot of fun and,
you know, cute clothes and...
-Yeah.
-I don't know.
-You got to --
You sort of made fun
of some people --
Emma stone, Lady Gaga.
Fun "making fun of."
-But in a nice way,
because I don't want to do
anything mean-spirited.
-It was very friendly.
But did you run into anybody
backstage?
-I said that Lady Gaga
did my eyeliner,
that she'd been
doing my eyeliner
for the last 15 years,
that she just --
She just can do anything,
was the gist.
And so I went back --
I got backstage,
like, right after the monologue,
and she was standing there
and she was like, "Oh, my God!
That was so great.
You're so funny."
And blah blah blah.
And she was super nice.
Like, really normal nice.
And I was like,
"Oh, good, thank you.
I mean, you know,
you're the real thing.
I mean, I'm with Tony Bennett,
your voice --"
Like, nobody has ever told her
she can sing.
[ Laughter ]
So I was like, "I'm really --
really gonna blow her away
with this one."
[ Laughter ]
And she was so nice.
She goes, "Well, you should come
see my jazz show in Vegas.
You know, it's
all that kind of music."
And I thought, "I'd love to."
And I said, "You know,
I feel like I'm gonna
call you Stephanie."
And she said,
"You can call me Stephanie!"
I mean, isn't that nice?
-That's really nice.
-Because that's her name.
-Yeah.
That is her name,
for anybody who doesn't know --
because otherwise,
you sound like a crazy person.
-Yeah.
"I'd like to call you Pam!"
-"I'm gonna call you Bill."
[ Laughter ]
She is a lovely person.
-She was so nice.
-And that is -- I mean,
I think -- the only reason
to go to those shows is to have
those, like, actual in --
like, sort of nice moments
backstage that are --
-Yeah, backstage is
where it's at, man.
You know,
just walking by people,
just like, "Hey!"
it's great.
-Yeah.
-I love it.